[Music]
so where did be the genesis for this
book come from it came from so funny
because we've almost exclusively talked
spoken here about gay rights and it's
only one chapter in the book well I want
to explain because I wanted to get it
out of the way and yet when you zoom to
everything except you've now added a
question the answer is the Brendan Eich
mozilla episode of 2014
yeah connect fresh people Armen yes so
this was the gentleman out here in
California who helped co-found mozilla
the internet company and he was elevated
in 2014 to CEO of that company and then
it was revealed that he had donated like
a thousand dollars it was private money
to Proposition 8 which here in this
state was the one man one woman
amendment 2008 passed by the way in this
you know back woods right wing place
California and this was this was a
thought crime that could not be
tolerated
eventually to make the long story short
he was hounded out of the company that
he founded for holding a mainstream
political position that Mary Katherine
and I happened to disagree with him on
but we were very troubled by how that
all went down and that was actually the
catalyst to get off of our asses and
write this thing because we're like can
you boo like this is this is scary we
disagree with him but what happened to
him doesn't really feel like America to
us they were like you know someone
really ought to write a book about this
we're like oh crap it's us that's a lot
of work as you know yeah um but it was
worth it and now the book just came out
in paperback this month and the reason
that we finally decided alright we need
to update this thing so end of
discussion came out in June of 2015 one
week before Donald Trump announced that
he was running for president so his name
did not appear in the book once and so
the new chapter that we've added to the
paperback edition begins with the line
Donald Trump is president and Berkeley
is burning perhaps we should revisit our
subject and what finally put us over the
top was Mary Katherine got an email from
the LA Times actually
weeks and weeks ago at this point saying
you know with everything happening in
Berkeley and Middlebury we'd love for
you to write an op-ed about your new
book and then ten minutes later she got
a response email again saying it has
come to our attention this is not a new
process but it was there as red-hot
unfortunately hotter than ever in terms
of the topic which might be good for
book sales but it's bad bad news for the
country do you see any hope for the
counter movement to the end of
discussion that's happening in about
yeah right now yeah for a number of
reasons you know the we anticipated in
the book a backlash we had no idea that
it would come so quickly in the form of
really Donald Trump loses this giant
middle finger to this entire culture and
some people like oh is that really what
happened it's not by any stretch the
entirety of it but if you don't believe
that political correctness and the
backlash against that was not a huge
part of the appeal of Donald Trump I
think you're asleep
I think it's indisputable in my view so
yeah I think that the when it comes to
this backlash and some of the hopeful
signs one is there have been increasing
efforts at pushback from the Academy
from within a dozens of professors at
Middlebury wrote and signed this amazing
letter about free expression after that
whole incident went down
Jonathan height from NYU has started
this heterodox heterodox University or
Academy Academy which i think is
terrific and people are signing up
because I think there are people on the
left looking over their shoulders saying
I thought I was a liberal and good
standing but you know who knows who the
jackals are going to come after next
this is getting out of hand so that's
that's where we really derived some hope
where we're telling folks and we speak
on campuses and we really wrote the book
not to be a right-wing pound the table
book we're trying to persuade people not
to necessarily agree with us on every
issue but to join us on this this
fundamental question of are we going to
be a society that can actually talk
about things or
not and if I can't talk about things
anymore we're not going to solve any of
our problems so in a sort of selfish way
but I guess also in a societal a every
time this eats another liberal or lefty
or progressives you must love it right I
mean like like to Evergreen State thing
with Brett Weinstein oh my god you must
have loved it because here's this guy
that the furthest left college now he's
the furthest left professor deeply
progressive as he said to Tucker Carlson
and they ate him so you must be gone
guys I'm we uh I told you yes you should
buy the book um the the one that I get a
kick out of still is it's a fuel a few
years old now this example but one of
the things that we argue and then the
discussion is that like the left is
forgetting how to argue even amongst
themselves right it's not just all this
demagogic fire at the right that's been
true for a while that's getting worse
this is their form of argument now this
is their you know identity politics and
the imputing of motives and outrage has
supplanted rational argument and so
there was this episode towards the end
of the Obama presidency where there was
a dust-up on the left over TPP so we are
talking about trade policies yeah okay
we're not talking about trans bans or
anything trade policy and Elizabeth
Warren the word trans was in it though
that is that is true trans-pacific that
is though it may have confused a couple
people but good pull that being said
point taken the President Obama was on
the other side of this issue from
Elizabeth Warren senator who we also
really go after in the book and a sort
of delicious way but I digress
at one point Obama was asked about
Warren's criticism of TPP and he
responded by saying well Liz blah blah
blah and a bunch of people on the Left
were like whoa did you just refer to a
sitting senator by first name that is
really mansplaining and patriarchal and
really problematic and including some
members of the Senate were attacking
Obama for using her first name and so
we're like sitting back with a giant
thing of popcorn and we're like oh
excuse me but are you criticizing our
first Bo
black president because that seems kinda
racist based on your whole thing and it
got into this sexist versus racist thing
I'm like you guys this is it this is
getting bananas yeah and so I don't know
sometimes we try to give those types of
examples to say to liberals like it's
not we're not the only victims of this
and I also wanna make one other point
the left isn't the only perpetrators and
say that's exactly where they're going
way after your questions right now well
no I'll let you do it but what I wanted
to know is because that's what people
say to me all the time that I'm now
because I've so exposed this thing and
I'm so focused on this intersectional
monster that will eat everyone and it
will piss actually black people against
gay people and at the oppression
Olympics and we've all you know
victimhood is virtue in this whole thing
that somehow I've let the right off the
hook here so hook that right for me we
do yes so if we do and one of our goals
was to be intellectually honest and in
fact in the process of writing the book
before this was initially 2015 before we
submitted our final manuscript a very
good buddy of mine actually my ex's
brother he is one of the most well read
sharpest guys I know and he's he's an
attorney he's done very well his
credentials are impeccable academically
and I asked him I said look we're going
to be submitting this manuscript we want
to be intellectually honest I know
you're not going to agree with me on
policy issues a B or C would you do us
the favor and the honor of reading the
manuscript and giving us feedback not
about where we're wrong but where we are
not fair to people on your side where we
have intellectual blind spots that would
potentially turn someone off from being
persuaded by us so he read the whole
thing and he came back and he said this
is actually quite well-written kind of
like thanks um it's and it's funny and
I'm persuaded but here are six examples
of things where I think that you would
lose some credibility and we went
through all them and said this is legit
and we and we change the manuscript
beforehand because we really wanted to
be
fair and honest and that includes being
critical of our side and even our selves
we give an example in here where we have
contributed personally to this problem
as well yeah so where have you
contributed to it so I remember and part
of this is just sort of the imputing of
motives and this the over-the-top
outrage I was on the air in Chicago I
had a radio show my first sort of gig
out of college I had a weekend show in
Chicago and I was on the air on a Sunday
night in March of 2010 when Obamacare
finally passed into law and I had spent
month after month fighting this thing
and for good reason I was worried we
would never be able to uproot it and it
seems that that was a well-founded fear
and I had really poured my heart and
soul and intellectual all into this
fight and then I was watching it go down
live on the screen while I'm live on the
air and I remember the phone lines on my
radio show were absolutely jam-packed
ten lines from 15 minutes before the
show started until well after the show
ended people were so emotional and so
was I and I went on a rant during the
show about and I called out every single
Democratic Congress person from Illinois
and the surrounding states who had voted
for it and was doing a roll call of who
they had who we had to beat moving in
the next election by the way we bought
them up beat almost all of them but I
took it a step further and I was talking
about punishing their families and not
giving their kids jobs and not writing
letters of recommendation for their
children and it was it was too much and
it was it was unhinged outrage and that
was you know part of this outrage
environment that gets the better that
gets the best of our rational discourse
discussion sometimes so that was sort of
an example that I gave about myself and
then we also do this like during the
Iraq war there was this unfair
conflation of being against the war and
being against the troops and that's a
dishonest way of arguing criticizing
Israeli policy is sometimes immediately
called anti-semitic there is crossover
believe me but I think making that
argument right out of the gate is unfair
and then there is this impulse I think
on the right also to say black lives
matter is a
anti-police or Procop death organization
there's a lot of demagoguery about that
which i think is grossly
mischaracterizing how many people who
are associated with that movement feel
and what they believe and what their
genuine grievances might be and why and
so both sides argue this way
the reason that we do harder after the
left is because they control the taste
making institutions in this country they
control academia they control most of
the media and they control Hollywood and
entertainment and when you have that
heft on your side and you can sort of
impose the culture much more easily they
they are the bigger part of the problem
I have no doubt though if the roles were
reversed yeah
human nature and bad authoritarian
impulses are not relegated to one side
we would be doing the same thing I think
I completely agree and it's why you know
people every now and again I'll say
something on Twitter and someone will
find saying that I said five years ago
that was I said the other way and it's
and they'll be I gotcha yeah I'm like no
no actually circumstances change the
power of change I evolved which i think
is a little something of how humans are
supposed to operate and that power
corrupts and that suddenly you lose your
your moral compass and you're suddenly
magically in power I got it I was
tweeting about because during the health
care debate this most recent healthcare
debate just the rhetoric on the left is
unreal it's like the Republicans are
going to kill thousands of people any
million theaters strip 22 million people
from their health care is just like
detached from any fair reading of
reality but it was you know we have to
beat this no matter what we'll say
anything so I was objecting to this you
know they blame our rhetoric for stuff
that has nothing to do with our rhetoric
and then a week after Steve Scalise gets
shot by a Bernie Sanders supporter
Sanders is out there saying the
Republican health care bill would be
like nine 911s every year I'm like oh
like what are the what are the standards
here so I was objecting to something
that Hillary Clinton had said saying
that the Republicans would be you might
as well rename them the death party or
some
like that and I was like wow and some
lefty bloggers found a piece a short
blog post that I wrote in college like
11 years ago praising a book by Ramesh
Ponnuru which was called the party of
death and it was about abortion and he
was just like bang yeah gotcha gotcha
and I'm like it's it's sort of tough to
make a life comes at you fast meme when
it's like eleven years apart yeah and I
remember even at the time asking where
mash like do you think this title might
turn some people off anyway I get it I
mean that's that's twitter twitter
culture and we're not going to be
perfect like that's why we say in a
discussion we are not the exemplars of
perth like like pristine public
discourse at every turn we're just
trying to be better about it and we're
hoping to encourage others to join us
well it's funny because I always find
that I'm basically within these four
walls of this room I'm pretty much at my
best in terms of my intellect how I
treat people all the things it's already
Twitter
you're not pretty good in my private
life too but Twitter often brings out
the worst in me totally I'm fighting
with someone that I don't really care
about you know you see these outrages
all day long I try I'm doing it less and
less but just the other day I saw
somebody had tweeted something about
basically all the white interns now at
the White House you retweeted it and you
you grabbed I guess from their own
company's website how many white P they
were basically zero percent black inter
with the black intern or his leadership
team so he and said look at all these
white male interns that Trump has and I
just went to his bio clicked on his own
website of the company that he founded
and it's like meet the team yeah and the
team was mostly white dudes and no black
people so I just mirrored his tweet but
with his company yeah and that that kind
of went a little bit viral which I don't
think that that's over the top or like
sometimes you've got to fight back on
some of the stuff because they're fake
moralizing that is at that point like I
don't that's and that's the thing I
didn't think that this guy's company is
morally worse or bad at their work
because it's disproportionately fill in
the blank identity politics I just think
for
I think there's something really weird
in someone's head use a former Obama
official by the way yeah there's
something weird in someone's head when
they see a photograph of a hundred and
twenty college kids and the first thing
they do is like slop these people into
like gender and race immediately to make
some political point like if that's the
game you're going to play here's how
that might apply to you and I was by no
means embracing identity politics I was
ridiculing it and I think ridicule is
sometimes one of the better tactics we
have does that show you though how well
their tactics have worked for so long
because now the thinking has gotten so
sloppy so for help I saw a recent tweet
by Chris Hayes from MSNBC talking about
all the scar Moochie stuff which again
was it's happening right now as we tape
this but it'll be a couple weeks ago by
the time we aired this but saying
something about Carlucci might be
president pretty good for a tears he can
be President he could be put to Siberia
like we have no freaking clue what's
going to happen but Corey might have
connections in Russia he might have
connections in Italy you never know ah
well say I think that's been automatic
but but the point is I saw Chris Hayes
tweeted something to the effect that
these guys if these were black people
doing this in the White House everybody
would be up in arms I'm loosely quoting
him but I thought the idea that you took
saying that there there's no racial not
up in arms about it I mean how much more
often arms can people there so I maybe I
may not have been up in arms as the fray
a point but point being that you took
something that there's no racial
connotation to this discussion
in order to mean no one's claiming a
scar Muji's are racist or there's just
nothing racial about this and now you're
giving it the racial and just to give
the meat to the people that you're
talking about yep right here and I know
dangerous I know Chris and I like Chris
and sometimes we come at each other with
some brush back pitches on Twitter and
that's fine because I just be gratuitous
endless parade of identity politics it's
just completely exhausting and again
it's a substitute it's a shortcut to
sort of bypass any real debate and
that's actually the way that we describe
end of discussion it's how primarily the
left is trying to win cultural debates
and political debates by
preventing the debates from happening
they want to win by default
just because we're bad we're blankest
and therefore our ideas don't need a
fair hearing because obviously rights
are like this self-fulfilling tautology
they're bad because they're bad because
they're bad and end of discussion
and we're like now that's that's not how
this should go who's your kind of
Republican if you were looking at all of
them oh boy tell me on a Republican I am
open-minded truly of them give me give
me somebody that you think is doing this
thing right from from the Republican
perspective again you said you're more
of a conservative than a public alright
so just from a conservative perspective
who do you think is basically doing it
right I really like Ben Sasse the
Nebraska senator I think he's principled
I think he's really smart I think he's
got a great sense of what civic duty
means and shouldn't mean the humor he's
funny he does he does this stuff where
he goes to his home state and he works a
full day on a variety of jobs randomly
no press no cameras he'll go and work at
a mechanics shop for a nine hour day and
just like show me what you do talk to me
about your life he drives uber which is
that right he drives uber it's
incredible I just I think he's really
good and I'm sure you can find something
where I disagree with him or where I
think he's done something wrong but I
think he's great and I I really get the
sense in meeting with him and talking
with him that he means it when he says
the the goal of my life is not to be a
u.s. senator right that this is not the
end-all be-all of life and he's got a
really interesting book out as long as
we're plugging books I like in terms of
the Trump administration I really like
nikki Haley at the UN I think she did a
really nice job in South Carolina as
governor she navigated some difficult
things quite well
she has been willing to step out and say
things that are not necessarily the
exact party line all the time with some
moral clarity about some important
things and certainly not the UN parties
yeah yeah definitely not but not even
the Trump party what I'm saying so those
are two I don't want to exclude
there's plenty of people in the party
that I really respect and like um even
if they have their quirks and there's no
such thing as a perfect political figure
and when you start to think of their
area you're going to get super
disappointed yeah well that's also why I
focus on left because I came from the
left but also that they seem to have
this concept that if they could only get
their people in everything would be
perfect so it's never about the
principles it's only Barney would get in
or Elizabeth Warren get it everything
will become perfect and that's such a
that hero worship and again there's
plenty of people that worship Trump so
I'm not saying that doesn't again but
that sort of hero worship I think is the
most dangerous thing I would rather take
the power away from all of these people
yeah I think we'd be in better shape no
personality cults are weird and creepy
especially in politics and I think it
sort of Rob's people and reason where
and just like the double standard that
drives me it drives me crazy where you
have people and it's a tribalism right
people willing to defend that's almost
anything if it's their guy when they
would be going apoplectic if it was the
other side doing it and there's no real
argument for it other than well that's
them and they're bad and we're us and
we're not yeah we're good we're for
America okay the thing sort of like you
get with the program or get lost
CUC yeah is just like all right I mean
great you you persuaded me right right
like what and anyway but I don't think
most Americans are caught up in the the
hardcore like you know hero worship
thing I do think it's very odd how the
left in particular feels like they can
somehow perfect society through
political action and the governor is
horrible it's always messed up if we
only had more of it right it would fix
everything socialism's never really been
tried properly right Venezuela it didn't
know that there's reason it did yeah
they screw that up but believe me their
principles work get back to us on how
yeah yeah all right well let me ask you
a little more difficult question than
Republicans that you respect
are there any Democrats that you think
haven't gone completely insane
no they're all bad for America no I mean
look there there are some Democrats that
I certainly respect more than others
sometimes I'll play this game with so my
liberal friends like who you know who's
your favorite
and there are cop-out answers like you
know my favorite Democratic senator was
Zell Miller who you know who just gave a
wild stem-winder of a speech at the
Republicans that was the most confusing
thing it was the line like you never
remember lines from convention speeches
I remember him ripping into John Kerry
and saying what does he think we can
defend America with spitballs and
everyone went crazy um she bothers me
sometimes but I have to say that I
respect Dianne Feinstein I think that
she's not always predictable she's not
always a hack I think she takes national
security pretty seriously um I just take
America she's on her way out well no but
I think she has respect for institutions
I have to confess I like Joe Biden I
think that he is just sort of a fun do
that I like to hang out with but when
you see a guy like Biden or even when
you see the modern what what are thought
of as more of the moderate even though
they're probably all to big government
for you but when you think of like a
Chuck Schumer or a Biden or sort of that
older group do you think it's over for
that wing like do you think that the not
sure Bernie more counts as that right
right so when were somewhere in the
middle and I look I have no love lost
reduction or but like he also voted
against her they didn't really ever vote
on it but he came out against the Iran
deal yeah I thought was well that's what
I say though there's a little more of a
centrist he didn't read either party
line there I I see the left now dragging
the Democrats much further to the left
and do you see any chance for whoever
you think those moderates are whether
you include Schumer in that or Joe Biden
even though he's not everybody's very
worried that we are heading in a
European model direction where we have
an ever-growing state we have socialists
to the left and sort of more
nationalists to the right and there's
not much of a real home or constituency
for limited government constitutional
conservatism that is something that I'm
concerned about I think for a number of
reasons
I don't feel
we alluded to this earlier I don't feel
welcome in the Democratic Party and even
when I am at peak exasperation with the
Republicans the Democrats show up and do
something I'm like well nope yeah but
the Republicans have been trying awfully
hard to alienate me and I think part of
it is just like all right
try to stay intellectually grounded take
each issue and circumstance as it comes
and evaluate it as best as I can on the
merits and that's how I try to go about
my job writing a town hall giving
analysis on Fox News and that's the best
I can do and it's going to make some
people unhappy and that's fine and
hopefully some other people are going to
find it refreshing and I just sort of
let the chips fall yeah
so when you say Constitution limited
government all of that low tax stuff all
that kind of stuff what about a Rand
Paul to just it's the foreign policy
stuff that gets here yeah yeah I think
he's probably a little bit like I would
take him over his dad any day of the
week I I don't think and part of me is
also like there's a pragmatism element
here as well like I think it there are
certain people who are outside of the
Overton Window and of collectability
nationally now maybe I'm not the best
judge of that because based on all his
polling numbers I thought that the man
who was elected president couldn't be
elected he had the wonderful benefit of
running against a truly historically
atrocious candidate who's writing a book
about why she lost I'm sure that's going
to be really a wonderful compelling what
they called what happened what happened
what happened I mean what a terrible
name for it maybe healed one page book
maybe one sentence book I'm terrible
yeah the end you know but yeah Rand Paul
I don't know
this last election has made me think
long and hard about how many people
actually view the world and view the
political system the way I do I used to
think that people like me were the clear
majority within the Republican Party and
I am less convinced
than ever and so Rand Paul is I think in
theory I'm with them on a lot of yeah
I don't know if that is going to sell to
the American people I mean look at the
mean we elected a Republican president
who drew a line in the sand saying I
will not touch the entitlement programs
which are which have to be is basic math
and George will have this column if the
Republicans are no longer going to be
the party of math what is the point of
them and that's something that I'm
worried about
so it's interesting in an odd way I'm
frustrated with the left because I see
them going too far left big government
you're frustrated with the right because
you see them trending in that direction
too yeah yeah that's a really
interesting spot to be in and I do think
there was all this like thumb-sucking
analysis for years about how the
Republicans were this moving radically
to the right and they were
unrecognizable and there was very little
parallel commentary about what was
happening on the Left I don't I'm not
exactly sure what the Republican Party
is and what exactly it stands for aside
from not the left there's something
useful in being not the left
I think fighting the left is a useful
worthwhile endeavor but aside from sort
of the the anti left general impulse or
sentiment I'm not exactly sure what the
coherent philosophy of the party is
which is a weird feeling to have but
that's that's where we are I think for
me so one of the things that I've talked
about with almost everyone in the last
couple months we said anyone that's
political on the show has been that
almost everyone has been satisfied with
the destruction that's happening with
mainstream media right now you're sort
of on both sides of it because you're
you're a mainstream guy as you said you
do stuff on Fox but you do online stuff
as well like you know the fact that you
have a Twitter presence that's active
like you get internet culture I think
are you as satisfied as I am that
mainstream media is crumbling because
I'm pretty thrilled I think there's been
such a destructive aspect to it and to
your point earlier of they were we're
all leftist
and watching that crumbles
hopefully something more sane will come
out of it I may be wrong yeah that may
give all the power to the Alex Joneses
of the world yeah I mean I've I've
always believed in a marketplace of
ideas and not this top-down media
environment where you know for many
years for decades it was basically two
newspapers and three networks decided
what the news was and that was that and
slowly but surely people have been
chipping away at that with talk radio
and Fox News and of course now the
internet which I think it's is this is a
positive development for sure and I
think that the biased media that it's
still funny that they are always worried
about the credibility of other people
and they seem less aware that their own
credibility is like a thing that they
have lost in the eyes of many people
like when a lot of polling shows the
media less trusted than Trump like that
should be a wake-up call but for them
it's sort of like they're on this high
horse and it's in like it's not
penetrating yeah so I take a good deal
of satisfaction in sort of seeing some
of that come down because it's earned
they've deserved it I don't think it's
an unmitigated positive either though
because for two reasons first I do
believe in objective truth I do believe
that there is something that is correct
and something it is incorrect
and I think it is useful to have people
who are credible who can call those
shots and I'm not saying that the media
has epitomized this because they haven't
yeah but we do need those voices which
is why I appreciate people like Jake
Tapper or Bret Baier and there's a
number of them we need to value that
still and not throw the baby out with
the bathwater completely and then the
other side of this concern that I have
is we in this and in this current media
environment we can just construct
delightful comfortable cocoon like echo
chambers for ourselves where we pick and
choose like on Spotify the only stuff
we want to listen to and ingest and then
just dismiss everything else as fake or
biased or right-wing propaganda or fake
news or whatever you know the term is
going to be and that does not contribute
to a healthy society when you have large
sections of the country off in their
separate ideological silos where counter
arguments don't really penetrate and
there's not a devotion to truth and
intellectual honesty that's not I don't
think that's a positive so do you think
we could have a legit third party then
for the for the refugees of the last
that I like that I think I'm trying to
offer what what classical liberalism or
real liberalism is for guys like you
that are gone the party is actually not
doing the conservative things that I
want them to do you just think the
machine is too big machine and then also
just like so okay and here's here's why
I'm not optimistic on that front and
again I could be proven wrong I don't
think that I had a you know I have the
last word on any of this stuff but but
you're letting not everything you say
here will prove out to be absolutely I'd
give myself like a like a 92 percent
actors everything give or take I will do
is we go to the year okay with that or
just like play back the tape I sit here
with a bag over my head um but I think
the the data point I would point to is
the 2016 election right on Election Day
according to all the exit polling Donald
Trump had a 60% disapproval rating any
one Hillary Clinton had a 55 56 percent
disapproval rating these are toxic
people who most people did not like did
not trust
couldn't relate to it was our two major
parties putting out the very worst
really that they possibly could and they
still got you know combined for what
ninety-five ninety-six percent of the
national vote I mean the libertarians
put out a ticket of two former
multi-term governors who sort of crashed
and burned and were terrible Jill Stein
sort of a moon bat you know Evan
McMullen has turned out to be super
annoying like this was the moment this
was the moment like
these parties are failing they suck so
hard someone and and it was just nothing
so who knows someone might have morality
I wasted my vote on Gary Johnson I don't
think it's a wasted vote so I voted for
a third party as well
I felt I fell why I assume you mean Gary
Johnny 26 what other third party who you
voted for in 2016 hold that thought I
honestly felt like every person running
for president was actively trying to
lose my vote at all times like I'd be
like I'd watch Hiller I'm like gosh
she's awful yeah maybe the second look
at Trump then I turned him on like Oh
God
like all right Gary give it to me and
it's like nope
yeah nope nope nope and so it's like the
person that I heard from most recently
was the one I was most upset with all
the area um so that's but again I don't
think it's a wasted vote like I don't
think that anyone just deserves my vote
by the like I don't think the Democrats
deserve my vote because I'm gay I don't
think the Republicans always deserve my
vote just because I'm more with them
than not like it does take a lot for me
not to vote for a Republican but by god
it's been happening yeah but so who do
you vote for
I end up voting for McMullen really yeah
cuz he was on the ballot in Virginia I
actually sat in the booth or stood there
in the voters booth there were four
names on the ballot it was Hillary Trump
Johnson and McMullen I actually
interviewed Gary Johnson for Town Hall
in a sit-down like this oh yeah right I
saw it that was when I finally snapped
against him because you did a great job
of that in except the purpose of the
interview was to be like dude you're
this libertarian and you keep trying to
sell Bernie supporters like Selmy yeah I
should be your target audience so they
agreed they came we sat down and I
wanted to ask him about limited
government and all this stuff and he
jumped down my throat about using the
term illegal immigrants and got super
triggered by it and told me you can't
use that term and start shouting I was
like bro but what are you doing here I'm
so glad you mentioned that because I
forgot that you were the one that did
that and I talked about it because I had
about a
before the first debate I publicly did
this thing about why I'm going to
support Gary Johnson I just want new
ideas out there I want limited
government and no taxes to be heard at
least an individual right so bah-bah-bah
and I knew he wasn't it wasn't going to
work but whatever I said I'm gonna at
least try if I can do anything with my
voice let me try at least but then there
was the Aleppo thing and he couldn't
name the leader he liked but then your
interview to me was the one where it
like completely snapped and again he's a
decent man I you know but because he
kept saying the thing about because you
kept saying it illegal immigrant and he
said it's an incendiary term but you
kept asking him are they not illegal are
they not illegal and then at the end I
mean get correctly he basically was like
yes you're right and I was like that was
the worst I don't want to pile on the
guy what's the point anyway look I think
we're we did a nice job
I appreciate that but I stood there on
Election Day looking at these four names
and I really had this moment where I
contemplated checking the box for all of
them at some like running through the
list and the one that I felt least agita
or indigestion over at the time was Evan
McMullen although he seems to be working
over time since the election to make me
regret my vote for him with just sort of
the nonstop Russia area I believe that
the Russia investigation is important I
am NOT you know automatically inclined
to believe that Trump is or his people
are completely innocent or whatever I
think the way they've handled has been
terrible but the hysteria and the and
the feeding of that fire is just it's
too much and he's been at the forefront
of that and it's like oh man yeah there
were no good options on the ballot for
me and I know that's not true for a lot
of people there's probably people
watching screaming you know sort of like
of course Trump was the best option are
you stupid I see the argument for that I
could I could sit here and make the
cogent make America great again argument
totally and there are large elements of
truth to it just for me I found and that
we don't have to relitigate this
election it's so depressing but I
thought that he was fundamentally unfit
to be President and I thought she was
ethically unfit and ideologically
unacceptable well I like talking to
somebody that's trying to
you know stay true to their morals and
their philosophy in the midst of a
political thing with stuff all right
well I think we should do this again
sometime yeah you know we were going to
go out tonight but I think we would have
had the most boring game night people
think when gay people go out it's going
to be some incredible but I don't sense
that the two of us could we would have
fun but nice conversation but it
wouldn't have been like whatever they
think gay people are doing I don't think
we could have got there I mean I brought
I'm having dinner with friends who have
kids now oh yeah you I think I said
maybe I'll meet after and you were like
I got to get to bed early I mean this is
pathetic well hang on I this is this is
you're revealing all the secrets here I
how do you know that I don't have
glitter and ecstasy just waiting well
because the way you said glitter and
Industry yeah there's just no chance
it's been a long long day and I'm very
much looking forward to sleeping all
right I can lend you some glitter but I
can't go out unfortunately it was a
legend it was a pleasure talking to you
and for more on guys follow him on that
Twitter machine its act guy pee that's
it
Oh
[Music]